cynthia quiso ser minera desde niña y ha
vivido en primera persona el avance
imparable de la mujer en la minería
chilena y
la minería
pero ahora cuando éramos más 260 mujeres
entramos ahora tenemos un jumbo
en cambio una gigante en mantención
en todo porque ahora se encuentra mujer
entonces donde están más acostumbrados
hoy cynthia es la primera mujer en
latinoamérica en obtener la licencia de
jumbos telecomandados una de las
complejas imaginarias fundamentales en
el proceso de extracción de cobre no
exento de numerosos riesgos
porque la primera muy serios en pérdidas
el doctorado la primera vez mucho y que
esa aportación a una mujer pudo lograr
un equipo
en 2021 en esta mina se alcanzó la meta
después víctor puntos y fuerza laboral
fueran mujeres más de 300 operan aquí
incluidos de la plantilla total de la
empresa estatal de codelco la mayor
exportadora de cobre del mundo son
mujeres pero llegar hasta aquí supuso
romper prejuicios como la superstición
de que no podían entrar en la mina
porque traían mala suerte y accidentes
por mucho tiempo hubieron varias
barreras de entrada al ingreso de
mujeres partiendo de ley es bastante
anacrónica de que mujeres no podían
trabajar en las operaciones hasta
pasando por sexos inconscientes de que
la minería no era un lugar para mujeres
en temas más estructurales como que
había muy pocas mujeres estudiando
carreras de stem o asociadas a la
minería familiares y amigos que están
los videos de presencia es un modelo más
para que las niñas del país puedan ver
que la minería no es solamente para
andar es ocupar este otro nuevo espacio
del mundo tradicionalmente masculino es
una de las muchas conquistas femeninas
ocurridas en chile en los últimos
tiempos